foreign
who knows me knows that I love to talk
I'm a chatterbox just ask anyone
I like to think that I'm pretty good at
building rapport with my clients and
having spent just under a decade working
as a lawyer I tell you this is one skill
that really came in handy
now I remember this one Interstate
client in particular we got on like a
house on fire we spent months
corresponding over email and chatting
over the phone and then the day finally
came when we would meet face to face
so walk into the meeting room and there
she is I say hello and she kind of gives
me this odd look
and she says
oh
you must work for Marion
and I'm thinking what what does she mean
and then it Dawns on me
she must think I'm the legal secretary
or the assistant perhaps now not that
there's anything wrong with having those
jobs
but it seems that in her mind
the voice that she's heard on the phone
all these months doesn't seem to
correspond to the person standing in
front of her
rather unconvincingly at that point I
say
no I I am Mariam
and then I start to doubt myself
and all those months of Rapport building
just goes down the drain at that point
as I start again
from scratch
to win her over
I do of course eventually
win her over but
it was a lot of time and effort wasted
and ultimately yet another hit to my
confidence
and the thing is I have other
experiences like that one
and I know plenty of other folks who do
too
so today
I want to reflect on how stereotyping
unconscious bias and societal privilege
operates in such a way that creates an
unequal playing field for diverse
minority groups
now let us start with privilege
privilege is basically unearned
advantage
hey what the hell we really didn't do
much to earn it
it's basically access to or enjoying
rights because you belong to a
particular identity you're part of a
club
and here's the thing
I am owning up to mine
I am privileged hey and if you could
afford the ticket price you probably are
too
privilege is relative and it's
ultimately subjective
and those who have the most amounts of
it they're probably not entirely
conscious of it
because for the most part and as they
say privilege is largely invisible to
those who have it
now I work as a diversity and inclusion
consultant so I do spend a hell of a lot
of my day thinking about these Concepts
think about this
whose faces do you see reflected back at
you on your television screens
who holds the top positions in the top
ranks of society
now except for the few examples here or
there notice the general lack of
cultural diversity
yeah of course
the photos that you're seeing up there
are some of our top CEOs Vice
chancellors of universities Federal
cabinet and TV Personalities in
particular
now what we're actually exposed to every
day feeds the assumptions that we make
about people
we all tend to possess a strong tendency
towards people who physically resemble
ourselves
it's called Affinity bias
now experiments have shown us that the
brain actually categorizes by race in
less than 100 milliseconds
now according to Noble Peace Parts
recipient neuroscientist Eric candle
he argues that up to 90 percent of the
brain's behavior is actually unconscious
so these little shortcuts that the brain
makes these little implicit associations
these biases
for the most part they are done
unconsciously
and here's the thing inherent societal
privilege
means that some of us are given a head
start and what I like to call the race
of life and it's because of that Head
Start not just because we worked extra
extra hard
that there'll always be Miles Ahead
even if all the participants are running
at the same speed and with the same
ability so that's code for the same
amount of merits
or in this case
running the same distance
now it's well documented that women of
minority groups face even greater
hurdles as you can see
they face both social and institutional
barriers to full equality not just
because they're chicks but because of
things such as race religion sexuality
or disability
they basically have a double whammy and
that concept is referred to as
intersectionality
now
as an Australian woman who's originally
from Afghanistan and a Muslim
I get the triple Whammy
I get sexism I get racism and I get
islamophobia you know some people boast
about having a fan base well
ladies and gentlemen I have a troll base
clever Bunch they've totally mastered
the art of intersectional insults that's
not easy to do
now if only you had a dollar for every
time someone said oh but all
appointments should be on Merit
well of course they should be
but here's the thing
are we assuming that the existing status
quo is somehow based entirely on Merit
I'm not convinced that it is but hey
don't take my word for it
plenty of other people think that too
now I recall a conversation I was having
with two senior managers it was about
corporate Australia shift to start
focusing on cultural diversity within
its leadership ranks now that we're
doing better around gender diversity
one of them was a woman of Asian
Australian Heritage and she was a former
colleague of mine
the other a colleague of hers a man of
anglo-celtic origin now it's in the
context of this discussion in which he
turns to her the Asian Australian woman
and says
there you go another leg up for people
like you
now she's shocked because they're
colleagues so she says nothing
but I can't stay silent
I literally put hand out like this
caught up on my pedestal
and I said
when you extend a hand
to a group of people who for far too
long have been effectively walking in
the gutter
While others comfortably stroll the
streets that ain't no leg up
that certainly is not a handout that's
simply leveling the playing field
now Studies have shown us
that to Simply attain the same number of
interviews
as someone with an Anglo-Saxon sounding
name candidates from indigenous Middle
Eastern and Asian sounding names have to
submit a ridiculous amount of more
applications
so in this case when compared to Lisa
and Andrew and these are the real names
used in the study Nadine and Hassan have
to submit 64 more applications while
Ming and Hong have to submit 68 more
applications
guys we're talking about getting a call
back to secure an interview we're not
even talking about the kind of biases
that will kick in once you're actually
at the interviewing table
now I can't tell you the number of
crappy dad jokes I've had to make to
make interviewers feel comfortable when
they first meet me early on in my career
thanks for laughing
foreign
of Australians have at least one parent
born overseas no doubt that's probably
true of this Arena
that General diversity is not reflected
in the top ranks of society
now of course I'm not suggesting there's
anything wrong with this
assuming it is truly based on a
meritocracy and for culturally diverse
women like me well you know that glass
ceiling
it's double glazed for people like me
and that's why I've got heels like this
to be able to crack through it
only a tiny percentage of ASX directors
are culturally diverse women
at a CEO level it is even worse
so think about all those stats that I've
been telling you about
all those biases that we know about
what message does this send to a
generation of top HSE graduates who are
culturally diverse
I'm hoping that by this point some of
you are convinced
and the moral case for why change is
required to level that damn playing
field
but then there'll be others who won't be
convinced unless we show them the dollar
figures hey don't worry I've got it
covered
there is a thing called the diversity
dividend
now gender diverse companies are 15 more
likely to outperform their industry
average by culturally diverse companies
they're 35 more likely to outperform
theirs
so diversity brings me that a
competitive advantage
and here's the thing anyone at this
point who's thinking oh she means
tokenistic visible diversity now
I'm not asking you to whack on photos of
people that look like me onto your
website tickerbox
although that might be nice
no that's not what I'm talking about
real diversity brings about diversity of
perspective and diversity of views and
diversity of thought ultimately and of
course the inevitable flow on effects is
that Australian businesses will be able
to better reflect and understand the
needs of a multicultural Australia who's
ultimately their customer base
so with everything I've said I want us
to pause at this point and I'm going to
ask each of you to please stand
yes please stand if you can't stand then
I'll ask you
to please raise one hand instead
and you get to stretch your legs
no we're not doing a Yogo lesson
okay
I'm going to ask you a series of
questions
if the answer to the question is yes I
want you to remain standing or with your
hand up if the answer to the question is
no then I want you to take a seat and
the rest of the questions will be
directed at those people who are still
standing
please be as honest as you can
question one
did you have a job during High School
if yes keep standing if no please take
your seat
I quite like the power of ordering all
four thousand of you to do things
this is cool
question two
have you been discriminated against
vilified or abused because of something
you cannot change about yourself
and let's watch the room as we start to
see people sit
question three
at some point in your life you have felt
like you've been one of the few or the
only persons of your gender race Faith
sexual orientation or disability in a
room in an educational or professional
setting
and final question
have you attended a public school for
the majority of your education
what
knew that would get a few of us
okay
thank you for being brave enough to
participate by the way
if I answered those questions I would be
standing at this point
with those of you that are still
standing in the arena
I want us to reflect on our own levels
of privilege and what that means for
each of us I want you to reflect on
who's standing and who's sitting without
making anyone feel uncomfortable
but let's think about that
thank you for being brave and please
take a seat now
thank you
I want to tell you this
there's never been a more important time
for us to be conscious of our
unconscious biases and societal
privileges
you know when you driving and you know
you've got a blind spot back here you
know it exists but you can't see it but
you make a concerted effort to turn your
head each and every time to look
and to adjust
it's not enough to know that we've got
these biases and that we have these
levels of privilege you've got to do
something about it
we're living in an era we're divisive
politics has successfully otherwise
diverse minority groups and normalized
xenophobia against them we're constantly
reading derogatory headlines about
diverse minority groups
and what's worse is some of these
remarks are made by our elected
officials
now I believe that when you excuse
bigotry in words you lay the framework
to give bigotry in Action a free pass
we know that we have an urgent issue of
disenfranchisement amongst the youth
particularly those of diverse
backgrounds we want them to reach for
the stars
but the thing is you can't aspire to be
someone that you can't see
you can't address inequality equally you
can't
this is why I believe targets are
required across Industries where
diversity of this kind is lacking
now why you ask why targets because the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again and expecting
different results
thank you
the existing status quo has not allowed
us to reach a true meritocracy
so we need additional measures to give
us a bit of a nudge
because let's face it
what gets measured ultimately gets done
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen